[Music]
so it's a different way of thinking of
of your Keon okay
so I'm the
UK we start I'm using the Keon scenario
together there okay and he goes and he
has
you going to recognize K got it it's no
different than we're grappling right
we're over here and I get his wrist and
he recognizes crap he should not just
bend over and do that D do you
understand okay
so same thing in here yes we're starting
from here but once you got it you're I'm
countering his technique
okay and and I'm going to attack at
another
level going
under into the
leg
okay so here we should never
feel that you see that that is him uh
connecting to my
Center he feels
air
in okay make sense that I just get to
that playing field that that play will
make pottery with it okay go
[Music]
so let's go back to the the
Keon right I'm
here I feel everything's working good
okay and from there I go to this next
control point do you see
this counter doesn't feel anything like
that okay so it might
look to the iido la la
people that he went
down and that he turns around and that
you're going to get that
part you you're not going to get that
part you you get that so you you don't
you got to give up up the arm cuz you
didn't have the arm so you have to give
up the arm okay so as as I going here
you feel void right you're going to not
go here and try to get that
arm you're going to
reposition so I'm going around here I
don't feel that but I'm
reposition you see that where did you
reposition to the back get to the back
get to the the back okay
so you're not going to be in front of
him when he turns around you see so for
example I'm here I go here he starts to
turn around you're trying for that arm
he's going to keep going and that's
exactly what he
needed you get
it
instead you feel the void and you just
follow him and you're not he turns
around you go ahead turns around you're
not there you're not you're not you're
not you're
not there got it do you understand let's
try the leg take down pull your arm out
[Music]
everything so prioritize positioning got
it
so that's the drill right
here you lose it stay with the
circle don't plant your feet and try to
regain control of that that's the Deep
that's the difference we're doing
tonight here void move it his Circle
this is where we're at okay let's try it
go
so again I
know that you're thinking he turns
around you're going to get you're going
to get that you're not going to get it
stop it okay and this is now as cuz he's
trying to RI his hand out attack bring
his shoulder in there's the knee knee uh
attack about it so you're not you're not
going to freaking get it and if you did
it wouldn't be iido cuz you're
contestant you see so what we're doing
instead he countered he's go around I
reposition you see and now I attack the
back so I'm here and I'll just sit on
his head
okay again strong
P sit on his head okay that that's the
first thing knee is close to him and you
didn't give up control here
okay when I I'm going to give you this
progression this move here sit on this
head meaning my I have knee pressure and
foot pressure at the same time I'm not
off my feet okay just close contact so
let's get there and then we'll build on
it
okay all right you okay all right so
you're doing the same thing oh I felt
the counter I come up here I kneel down
okay the next thing is to keep control
of the arm you want to be distal so you
don't want to you don't want to let that
happen Okay so watch How
I do this as he's trying to counter when
you try that other technique that's what
allows him to pull the arm towards
towards him down okay cuz you're pushing
down he pushes down and now he's in the
knee bar
okay in this
technique this arm goes here do you see
and I'm controlling it disty you have a
couple options this is one of them right
so I'm at the distal end and my hip is
driving into him okay to lock that in
place another option is a two onone from
the from the forearm so I'm in this that
might be necessary is really strong ear
here like that
okay so I can use my forarm I can do it
two on
one another one is you can leave it
there and go two on two on one and not
go to the forarm grip do you understand
does that make sense okay then you'll
have
this
lowering so I'm going to go from his
head and I just shave him do you get it
that's what I'm doing I'm shaving
him as we're going that way as I'm
keeping him tight so I'm here I
shave and I'm in this
[Music]
break oh
shave and you fall into the break which
we do as a
tap
okay you're you're down okay and when
I'm
here it's very common you want to turn
this foot around now you don't have the
technique TI okay what I'm doing is I
won't do the lock but what I'm doing is
just
falling you see that
hey I'm not I'm not kicking this foot
around because that turns my hips so I'm
just here and I just fall into it then
by keeping your arm you stay tight to me
right
okay
go you don't have to do it fast but I'd
like to see it's
smooth you
see you don't see me doing that weird
turn right okay let's just look at the
mechanics of the technique so he's down
okay and
okay this this leg is not necessary for
the break it does not need to go across
his body so we're we're not bringing it
across this leg
is so this
leg is going to pin his head
down so you don't want to pull him in
with your knee up because with with your
knee up he can sit up he sits up he
starts to get out of it you push your
knee down by extending your leg do you
feel that so no pressure push it down a
lot of people bring this in to keep him
close that's not what keeps him close
you the arm keeps him close and you're
maneuvering okay this goes that way if
you come back
I'm not a fan of using the pubic bone or
the testicles for breaking people's arms
so his elbow at the tricep tendon of
insertion is going to be broken on my
inner
thigh that means that his thumb's not
going to be
up his thumb's going to be at the angle
make a thumb that I can break this
on my inner
thigh my inner thigh is going that
way my two hand grip is going
perpendicular to it as I do
this it's not going down on my stomach
look
nothing I lift
up different look at this I have all
that all that range of motion to do this
break okay okay so this the variant I
like let us make sure we have those
mechanics okay a stronger variation of
the technique but there's more
transition and uh transition
requires things you might not have time
and space okay but they might move into
it so that's why I teach these these
pairs okay so he goes to the counter I
come in around here and I take it this
way okay and so I still obeying the
leverage law okay make sense I I'm going
to drw I'm going to loosen it so I can
drop safely I drop the
same I might fall all the way but I come
up eventually and then I do it this
way so my whole body all my cord
everything plus my body
weight and the arm's going to go okay so
do it
again here this way and you just same
fall same Su I'm going to loosen it for
safety I might go all the way but then
you come back up and then you do
it please do it in two stages like that
cuz I don't want you in the in the
street you you don't fall the
arm relieves the structural integrity
and that's why you fall but in training
leave it Loose go
down come back up and reset it without
the inertia falling okay